Sho what a stop best of the night putting
on his show that was amazing flashing the
lever mdav he on meets a good set up by Bru
and he made a fine stop oh I agree excellent
and colorin is you get the jump on the push and
a nice glove save from [Music] brat over comes
he couldn't get it o Conor shot save rebound
another save har got him twice around tip and
a shot save by Hart and he gets his leg on the
rebound what a save by Carter Hart great stuff
by Hart as he keeps this a 3-1 game brings it
up the right side cager towards it it in oh
a jam play two tries and Levi Down and Out LS
were spread he found the puck and that's just
really strong by Devin Levi as he's right
up against the goal line Devin Levi really
strong up against the post to not allow that to
fully cross the goal line out of the box Monahan
Coffield shoots what a stop best of the night
dein Levi putting on his show in his hometown
that was amazing flashing the lever that's a
great shooting opportunity for Coffield gets
all he wants on it but Devon Levi comes out
challenges big glove save to keep this game
5-1 The Fakes oh mono reach back with his
stick a great move by Savanah J and M with
a desperation save Standing Ovation here in
Montreal and for good reason look like a wide
open [Applause] net Michael with Maro Mel with
Maro and bosi with a great stop oh what a chance
for Jonathan Maro Michael to marsho and what
a save by Bovi as he spreads out to his left
makes the pad save on Marsha so The Cider
the Kane to break it oh what a save that
ever oh my God what a stop by doall there's
been great saves at both ends by both these
goalies but that might be the best of the night
they got the look they wanted to break and snap
that one off and doto keeps a tie Jer brat
ner and Tyler to Foley and oh to Foley is
robbed by Tempco that was a 10 Bell save Tyler
to fo I can't believe it what a move he made in
and somehow Demco makes a save good patience and
everything but Demco got the glove up to make the
save backs this circled from behind the n
a shot by haena it pops up in the air it's
still available at the side of the net and flurry
somehow comes up with this Puck this is no can of
corny either I think Mark Andre flurry's got
to try to locate this bouncing on front after
hitting the stick it's an unbelievable glove
save he can't believe it bumps his way past
fa a two-on one short-handed San across and
flurry made that save rope hits he stares at
the Raptors he can't believe he didn't have his
second shortage just an elephantine stop to keep
this to nothing the number of stars that have
had that type of expression because of flurry
just improbable takeaways how he's looking to
get it out look out Maran right to the run he's
denied Rebound in front oh what a stop Ingram
robbed coy coy thought he had one he had his
arms in the air oh my and then that right skate
watch the right foot boom wow right on the line
Coyle thought he had it Conor Ingram had the
answer oh my goodness Johansson tried to catch
up with the play bean sends it across and a glove
save by flurry what a sensational stop shikov can
only shake his head with the flexibility the
athleticism big push good hockey IQ reads that
play the whole time he's the man you want to get
this Puck he gets it look at the open net whoa oh
that is incredible he reaches across and snags it
out of the air and Chino's reaction says it all
oh coming back the other way and out in front
one chance two chance oh r on side what a save
oh mercy atie let's see how big that is now he
gets it with his toe either way a spectacular
save great stuff Mark just played it in time here
here's a steel Ling back as Marr and somehow keeps
it out well he would draw up that way you would
not bullet dodged by the Flames that was close
it wasn't necessarily a bad play by marks you
could see the smile on his face there left at
the line for Anderson L all put it in front big
save by LOL off Shar K that was a terrific stop
with the left PAD as Sharon goic looking for
a second goal the third period Rob by lanin
it as they were retrieving a loose puck now it's
neander pulls it in doall makes the safe little
rebound swiped at by tamarus at the side of the
net Matthews cannot jam it home the initial shot
is blocked but the rebound sits there he gets
across for the rebound and boy leushin came to
his rescue watch he L leushin on the back
door here get his stick towards this Puck
that's squirted along the goal line he saves
a goal Hegel drives in centers and a sliding
save by flurry Mark Andre flurry trying to keep
the wild in it he stops Nikita kucherov Sanford
moves in wrap around try scolling his Skinner to
pin his glove up against the Left Post and keep
the puck out of the net Skinner has to battle
to get there and as denado has the puck right
in the crease you can see the puck never crosses
the line as Skinner is dove across a remarkable
effort